je pense que la turquie depuis 1923
depuis sa fondation essaie de combler
par une espèce de course en avant son
angoisse originelle celle du fait
qu'elle aurait pu ne pas être n'est ce
pas ou être réduites un petit plateau
anatolien comme le voulait le traité de
sèvres et donc à l'intérieur on poursuit
la construction quasiment mécanique à
d'une identité assez artificiel au
départ un peu moins artificiel
aujourd'hui qui est celle du turc aux
sunnites identité à la fois poétiques et
religieuses
le nouveau turc le turc régénérer devant
quelque sorte réaffirmé sa capacité de
domination à au moins régional un peu
plus si possible et ce turc l'a
évidemment qui s'est construit sur la
destruction de toutes les minorités eux
ce turc là aujourd'hui il trouve dans
l'islam cet islam que atatürk avait
nationalisé et bien erdogan
je dirais là où atatürk nationale avait
nationalisé l'islam erdogan d'un
islamisme la nation et dans le contexte
effectivement des années 1930
l'eia logis dominante c'était le
progressisme aujourd'hui c'est
l'islamisme et la turquie continue à
affirmer je dirais son ambition mais qui
comblent en fait une incertitude d'être
très profonde et pour moi la véritable
question c'est de savoir si la turquie
ne naples osera pas demain
[Musique]